Welcome back to the complete guide to Spin
here at the Rawkode Academy. In today's video,
we're going to carry on with our SDK
walkthroughs taking a look at the Python SDK.
Let's dive in. So in order to get
started with the Python SDK for Spin, you
will have to install the py to WASM
plugin. So to get started with the Python
SDK for Spin, the first thing you need
to do is make sure you are on
version 0.9
or greater. Once you have that version of
Spin available,
you can run Spin plugins update.
From there, you can install Spin plugins install
Pytorwasm.
And in order to generate a new Python
project with the Spin CLI, you will also
need to add with Spin template install
the Python SDK.
From there, you can generate a new Spin
project with Spin new and this will give
you a directory structure like so. We have
a pip file which has all of the
dependencies that we need, which for this example
is zero at the moment.
We also get an app dot py which
defines a handle request function and returns a
200 response.
We'll dive into the Python code in just
a moment. Lastly, we have to spin dot
toml. Here,
we can see the three components that we
expect
for all spin components. One, the build step,
two,
the trigger, and three, the ID and the
source simple. Now we can test that this
works as expected by running spin build.
From there, we can run spin up, and
this will show us that we have an
HTTP server running on local host 3,000.
Using curl,
we can confirm our endpoint works like so.
Perfect. So like the other SDK walk throughs,
what we're going to do is run through
some common tasks that are almost ubiquitous when
working with the Spin SDKs.
Our first endpoint, which we've already seen because
Spin new generated that all for us. We
have an endpoint that allows us to print
out hello world.
However, we'll make a small modification to this
and run through the build and run steps
one more time. From there, we're going to
take a look at how we work and
interact with HTTP
for Spin component.
We're going to get the headers, parse HTTP
body, and even parse and understand the query
parameters.
Lastly, we'll take a look and make an
outbound HTTP requests with the Spin SDK. So
let's make that first change to our Python
code.
What's important to note here is that this
is just any regular Python program like working
with any of the Spin SDKs.
You don't actually need to learn anything new
to start building web assembly components.
So let's show we can add hello world
on the CLI
minus
an extra quote. So let's modify
our simple generated
endpoint to return a JSON payload.
First, step one, make sure we're returning the
correct content header
or content type header as part of the
HTTP response.
Next, we're gonna import from JSON
dumps
assuming that I can remember how to type
any Python code. Next, we're going to remove
this f string and then use our dumps
function with a Python dictionary
where we will see that my name
is David. And I don't have a Python
format installed,
so I'll just do it the hard way.
Next, run spin build,
spin up
and we'll run a curl one more time.
Only this time, I'm feeling rather confident
and we're gonna pipe it straight to JQ.
And as you can see, we have the
print statement
running on our spin up here
as well as the JSON output from our
HTTP response.
So that is our first HTTP endpoint with
a simple modification to work with JSON.
Nice.
So let's talk about request headers.
How do we get the headers from HTTP
request being made? And before we dive straight
in to type in some code, I have
a confession to make. Unfortunately,
the LSP for Python is not going to
help us to auto complete our way to
victory in this code.
And there's some interesting reasons why.
So first, why am I telling you this?
Well,
normally, what we would do is provide enough
typing to our code like so to
autocomplete
on headers, methods available on headers,
on the body,
on the status, and so forth. However, as
you can see on the screen here, we
see unknown for request.
And this is because the Python SDK for
Fermion Spin is not written in Python. So
the traditional Python tooling for LSP
just isn't going to work.
And that's because the Python SDK for Fairbion
Spin is
written in Rust.
Now the team are actively working on getting
bindings for LSPs
available for the SDK, and hopefully that will
be available very, very soon.
But for today,
your best friend is the code.
So if you go to github.com/verimeon/spin-python-sdk,
you will find the crates directory, which has
the Spin Python engine directory.
Inside of that, you will find source and
a single lib dot r s.
Now you do not need to be able
to read Rust to get the help that
you need. As you can see here, we
have a struct. This is just a type
definition, and we can see all of the
properties available on the HTTP request.
We can see the method, the URI, the
headers, and the body. This works for all
the types you'll have to interact with as
you build your Python SDK, Fermion Spin applications.
What's important to note here is that the
headers are a vector, a vector of tuples,
where the tuple is a string string type
or a string string tuple.
Now Python supports tuples, doesn't have vectors, but
it has lists. If you're familiar with Python,
and I assume you are because you're watching
this video,
that means that we actually can't really do
headers dot get name with a default value
because
this get is working against the list, then
we'd have to destructure the tuple and so
forth and so forth. So what we actually
need to do is choose a nice little
Python trick,
which is to convert
our list of tuples to a dictionary like
so.
And this becomes
all headers. So now we're in a position
where we have an API.
And if you've seen the other SDK videos,
we should be familiar with this now,
where we can use a formatted entry point
to string or an f string in Python,
where we say hello.
And here, we'll do all headers,
and we'll just fetch out the name property.
And I'll call this
x name just because we're using an HTTP
header, and custom headers usually start with an
x dash. Now the case isn't important. It
will always be lower case when made available
to you within the SDKs.
But now that we've used our trick of
converting our list of tuples to a dictionary,
we've formatted our string,
we can pop over to the terminal,
do a spin build, and a spin up,
where we can now provide our x name
header
and curl
our local
endpoint.
Like so.
And, of course, just to show that this
is real, although I know you all trust
me by now, we can pass in the
value that we want, and it will be
formatted as part of the response.
So two things to take away here. Yes.
It's crappy. We don't have LSP,
but trust me, it's coming soon, and it's
gonna be amazing. Two, use the Rust code.
Again, you don't need to be able to
write Rust. Find the struct, get enough information
on the properties,
and the code will almost write itself.
Sweet.
Next up, issue to p request body.
This one, super simple.
You do body equals
request dot body,
and we'll print this to the CLI.
But while we're here,
let's change our from JSON import stump to
also pull in the loads function.
From here, we can say that our object
equals
loads
and this will parse the string of the
HTTP body as a JSON string.
Meaning, we can now do print
and say
f string
name is
object
name,
like so. So let's go back to our
CLI where we can build
and up.
Now we can do a curl to local
host 3,000,
only this time
we'll provide a JSON body where we'll set
the name
like so.
Now we're still getting the standard JSON response
that we set earlier, which just has hello
world of x name is not defined. But
as you'll see on the terminal output above,
the standard print of the body returns the
bytes with the JSON string followed by the
name as Rawkode after we've loaded the JSON
and consumed one of the properties. Sweet.
Okay.
Let's do the query string. And to make
our lives a little bit easier,
we're gonna hard code our response and remove
everything that we've done so far. Now much
like the body, the query string is available
as a single property,
but it's gonna need pars from that property.
We can grab the entire URI by asking
for request URI.
Now if we print this now, what we'll
see is we get a full string with
the protocol,
the host, the port if it exists, the
path, and then anything beyond the path such
as the query string or
fragments. But Python provides
some standard library components that allow us to
parse all this.
So we can see from URL
lib
dot parse
and port
URL
parse,
as well as parse
qs for query string. This means that we
can say the query string
equals
to URL parse
on the URI
and we want to create a component. Copilot
is always one step ahead. Next, we're going
to want to get to query string as
a dictionary.
And for this, we'll just call this params,
which is going to be equal
to parse the query string from above. So
let's do a pretty print of this to
our terminal. So as always, we do a
spin build
and a spin up where we can now
curl local host 3,000
and pass some parameters.
And here, we'll just say
that name equals and a b c equals
some values. You will have to quote this
to stop your terminal pulling out that ampersand
like so. We get the hard coded response
back which is fine, but in our CLI
output, we could see the query string and
the parsed keys and values. Now you can
do whatever you need with the query string.
Tada.
Now finally, we're going to make an outbound
HTTP
request. Let's pop open our simple generated app
dot py and we'll add request to the
spin HTTP
as well as HTTP
underscore
send. These function names are the same as
other SDKs and if you need to dig
into it, remember you can always check out
the Rust source code for the SDK that
you want to interact with. Now down here,
we can see response equals
HTTP send
where the send takes a request. Now the
structure of a request requires the method,
the URL,
parameters,
and throw on a none for good measure.
Now, of course, good measure is not always
a good reason to add arbitrary values to
function calls. Well, remember, check out the code.
And it should be request
takes a message, a URI,
headers,
and a body. As we can see from
here
and from here,
the body is an option type. So providing
none just means we want no body. I'm
not going to parse the HTTP response from
this request.
Instead, let's just pretty print it
and pull in the pretty print function
like so. Now we could jump back to
our terminal.
Uh-huh. Exactly.
And type in your curl.
Awesome. If you've seen any of the SDK
videos before, you'll know that 100%
we always expect destination
not allowed.
Why?
Rate and spin components,
you have to very explicitly
allow outbound request to the host that you
want to speak to. As such, we need
to add something to our spin.toml.
In your component,
you can see allowed HTTP
hosts
equals
google.com.
We can jump back,
spin up and build
like so. Now we've made our HTTP response
to Google.com.
However, you'll notice that we have a response
object with a funny value inside of our
terminal. So what do we do? We jump
back to the Rust source code. We can
see their HTTP response as a status,
headers,
and a body. So let's modify our code
for the status,
the body,
and the headers.
We'll spin build up and curl. Now we
can see lots of bytes for the body
at a status code somewhere at the top,
somewhere at the top, 200.
With our headers being at the very bottom
that we've we got them here. Don't you
worry. So that is the Spin
SDK for Python. So Python is your jam.
Start writing WebAssembly components using Fermion Spin today.
The developer experience with the language server protocol
type ins and easier documentation is all coming
very soon. Remember to check the description updates
will be coming soon. Of course, feel free
to just go check out the repository available
at github.com/fermion/spin-python-stk.
Watch it. Follow for new releases.
Fermion ship fast and changes will be coming
very very soon. That's the last time I'm
gonna see soon in this video. I'll see
you soon.